Speaker 1: Okay. Let's go next to Jim
from Chattanooga. Jim, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. A long time
viewer. How are you.
Speaker 1: Doing? Doing well.
Speaker 3: I guess my question is how to
reframe kind of basically the basic idea is
there's going to be pain. And I think Democrats
are struggling with this. Basically, a lot of
the problems are right now that we're suffering
from are from kicking the can down the road. And
a lot of the solutions tend to have short term
sacrifice involved. How do we reframe that? So
people that are in their sixties who will never
enjoy a working universal health care system
are willing to make that sacrifice.
Speaker 1: Well, this isn't really
like a new thing that humans do. I mean, I
think for most humans with a normal emotional
landscape, the idea that we might do something
that's good for the species we belong to,
even if I won't personally benefit from it, is
still a completely reasonable thing to do. I mean,
you know, the interstate highway system took a
very long time to build and many of the people
that supported their tax dollars going to it
didn't live long enough to enjoy it. And I mean,
it's it doesn't seem I think
the weird thing to me isn't
what the weird thing to me would be that more
people wouldn't, of course, understand that
the way things are, the way some of the good
things we have today, we have because people who
didn't benefit from them were okay supporting them
financially and that as a result we should do the
same thing to keep improving society. It would
be great if we have to explain that to people,
then we're in real trouble.
Speaker 3: So you don't think
the attitude around that has changed?
Speaker 1: I think that it hasn't changed in
terms of people's emotional understanding of it.
But I do think that the political system we have,
including these terms of two, four and six years
that don't really encourage long term thinking,
they encourage what can I do to justify my
next reelection? That definitely is not good.
Speaker 3: Right. And I think that's just a
feature. Yes. Yeah, absolutely. System. Thank you,
David. All right. Thank you. Just one more thing.
A screening of vasectomy next week. And I thought
maybe you could comment on that. 36, no kids.
Speaker 1: Hmm. That's interesting. You know,
most many, many urologists won't do a no
kids vasectomy for people your age. How
what was the conversation like?
Speaker 3: Well, I found one in Georgia,
so I'll be traveling.
Speaker 1: Oh, so you're
admitting it was hard to find one? You have
yet to go to find one in a different place.
Speaker 3: Not just find one, David. Find one
that's affordable, like under $2,000. It's not
just if you don't have money, you can't just go.
I don't know. People think that these things are
just out there to go grab a shelf somewhere.
Speaker 1: But did you talk to two urologists
who said, you know, for someone in your
situation, I don't really do vasectomies.
You don't have kids. You're only 36.
Speaker 3: I honestly didn't even work
here in Tennessee because I didn't
want to deal with it. Oh, okay.
Speaker 1: All right, good. Well,
so why are you do it? You're just
very sure you never want to have kids.
Speaker 3: Well. And I live in Tennessee.
I mean, I don't want to be forced
into fatherhood. Sorry. I just don't.
Speaker 1: Okay. What do you mean by that?
Speaker 3: Well, I think we had a
trigger law here. So when Roe was
overturned, I think it's six weeks
now. It might be six weeks, but it was.
Speaker 1: Oh, I see what you're trying.
Speaker 3: I seriously.
Speaker 1: And he thought to
maybe freezing sperm. So you have the option.
Speaker 3: Oh, no. There's there's probably a
little couple of Jimmy Sloan out there somewhere
they can, you know. I'm just kidding, David. I'm
just kidding. No, I haven't considered. Okay.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good, Jim. Thank
you. Good luck with the procedure.
Speaker 3: Larry, David, thank. Right.
Speaker 1: Take care of everybody. Okay. We're
going to take a quick break. If you're holding,
don't hang up. We are going back to the
phones on what has been an eventful day,
an eventful day. Stand by. Right back to the
phones in a moment. Let's go back to discord
and hear from a few more people. David Pakman dot
com slash discord is the place to be. Let's go to
Scott from Scotland, who is Scottish? Welcome,
Scott. Scottish Scot from Scotland. You are
self muted. Unmute yourself please. In order to
be able to talk to me, you have muted yourself
locally. Please unmute yourself so that we can
talk. And final chance for Scottish Scot from
Scotland to unmute yourself. I've unmuted you.
You do need to unmute yourself to be able. To
talk to me. I would love to hear whether Scottish
Scott from Scotland even really has a Scottish
accent but can't seem to get it all technically
happening. And Scott is gone. That's too bad.